- [Bill] Geoff, let's have
a look at the replay here
to see if indeed he
did do the three pumps.
- [Geoff] All right, no question.
There is the first one, right?-
- [Bill] Yeah, agreed, right.
- [Geoff] And then coming up,
is the second one.
- [Bill] Okay, yes, very clear.
It's the third.
- [Geoff] We'll see, it's
coming up right here-
- [Bill] Just not sure.
Oh, yeah, you're right, there's absolutely
three pumps there.
(crowd cheering)
(upbeat music)
(graphic whooshing)
(exciting music)
- Hi everybody, I'm Dave Stassen,
alongside Geoff Worthing,
and welcome to the annual East/West Bowl.
As we get ready to watch some of the best
college players in the
national showcase their skills
in a classic showdown
between East and West.
And there really are some characters
on this year's squads, aren't there Geoff?
- That's right, Dave, it does seem like
the most flamboyant personalities
came to the forefront,
and they are here.
Let's meet the players from the East.
(upbeat rock music)
(graphic whooshing)
- D'Marcus Williums,
University of Georgia.
(graphic whooshing)
- T.J. Juckson, Wayne State University.
- T'Variusness King, Merrimack College.
(graphic whooshing)
- Tyroil Smoochie-Wallace,
University of Miami.
(graphic whooshing)
- D'Squarius Green Junior,
University of Notre Dame
(graphic whooshing).
- Ibrahim Moizoos, University
of Tennessee at Chattanooga.
(graphic whooshing)
- Jackmerius Tacktheritrix,
Michigan State University.
(graphic whooshing)
- D'Isiah T. Billings-Clyde,
Coastal Carolina University.
(graphic whooshing)
- D'Jasper Probincrux The Third,
South Carolina State University.
(graphic whooshing)
- Leoz Maxwell Jilliumz,
East Carolina University.
(graphic whooshing)
- Javaris Jamar Javarison-Lamar,
University of Middle Tennessee.
(graphic whooshing)
- Davoin Shower-Handel, University
of Southern Mississippi.
(graphic whooshing)
- Hingle McCringleberry,
Penn State University.
(graphic whooshing)
- L'Carpetron Dookmarriot,
Florida Atlantic University.
(graphic whooshing)
- J'Dinkalage Morgoone,
University of South Florida.
(graphic whooshing)
- Xmus Jaxon Flaxon-Waxon,
University of Pennsylvania.
(graphic whooshing)
(upbeat rock music)
- We're going to be looking
for big plays all game long
from Tyroil Smoochie-Wallace.
- At let's not forget the
tight ends, Ibrahim Moizoos
and Hingle McCringleberry,
they've both had
amazing seasons.
- That's right, Geoff.
Now let's meet the players from the West.
(upbeat rock music)
(graphic whooshing)
- Saggitariutt Geofferspin, Texas A&M.
- D'Glester Hardunkichud,
University of Wisconsin.
(graphic whooshing)
- Swiruithan L'Goodling-Splatt,
Saskatchewan University.
(graphic whooshing)
- Quatro Quatro, San
Jose State University.
(graphic whooshing)
- Ozamataz Buckshank, Stanford University.
- Beezer Twelve
Washingbeard, Jones College.
(graphic whooshing)
- Shakiraquan T.G.I.F. Carter,
University of Northern Arizona.
(graphic whooshing)
- X-Wing At Aliciousness,
Missouri Western State University.
(graphic whooshing)
- Sequester Grundelplith
M.D., Adams State.
(graphic whooshing)
- Scoish Velociraptor Maloish,
South Dakota State University.
(graphic whooshing)
- T.J. A.J. R.J.
Backslashinfourth The Fifth,
Albion College.
(graphic whooshing)
(player imitating dolphin screeching)
- San Diego State University.
(graphic whooshing)
- Donkey Teeth, Boise State University.
- Torque
(construction machinery rumbling)
Lewith, Nevada State Penitentiary.
(graphic whooshing)
- The Player Formerly Known As Mousecop,
University of Missouri-Columbia.
(graphic whooshing)
- Dan Smith, BYU.
(upbeat rock music)
(graphic whooshing)
- [Bill] And we're coming to
the end of the first quarter
with the Rhinos in the red
zone for the first time.
- [Geoff] Gotta say, Bill, I
like watching these Rhinos.
- [Bill] Ransom takes the snap,
drops back with good protection,
and that's a completed
pass to a very wide open
Hingle McCringleberry, the
rookie out of Penn State.
- [Geoff] Nice grab by
McCringleberry, you think he's happy?
- [Bill] Oh, boy, he is
loving it down there.
- [Geoff] Oh, we got something of a
shooting gallery going on-
- [Bill] Oh yeah, look at
that, boy that is something.
And, oh, oh, wait, we got a flag there.
- [Geoff] What, he got called for-
- [Bill] Is that for
excessive celebration?
- [Geoff] Yeah.
- [Bill] Ah, see, I'm
not sure about that call.
- [Geoff] I don't know,
Bill, that was three pumps,
and the rule book says you
cannot have more than two.
- [Bill] Oh my gosh, but look at the kid,
he's pleading his case with
the ref, pleading his case.
- [Geoff] Yeah, clearly three pumps.
- [Bill] Coach Johnson definitely
not happy about this call.
- That's two pumps!
(graphic whooshing)
- [Bill] Five minutes
into the fourth quarter,
third in 10, the Rhinos
again threatening to score,
can the Cougars hold them?
- [Geoff] Big play coming here, Bill.
- [Bill] Ransom takes
the snap, drops back,
he floats one into the end
zone, and McCringleberry
pulls it down!
- [Geoff] Oh, he's got it!
- [Bill] Oh my gosh,
for his second touchdown
of the day for this
rookie, he has gotta be
feeling great about himself,
a lot of confidence-
- [Geoff] Nicely done,
I'll tell you man, he's-
- [Bill] Oh, oh see now
there's two pumps, oh-
- [Geoff] Yeah he's really
testing the boundaries,
and he's clearly gotten
the ref's attention here.
- [Bill] A third pump will
draw a flag no matter what.
(whistle screeching)
See, oh, he just did it-
- [Geoff] He did it again!
- [Bill] Now what is
that, the second time?
Now you have to flag him on it.
- [Geoff] Yeah, he had to.
You know, Bill, it's just
frustrating seeing young players
without the ability to
restrain themselves.
- [Bill] Oh it really is, it's hard.
- [Geoff] I mean the ref's
gonna get ya every time.
- [Bill] Yeah, yeah, absolutely.
See, now the ref agrees,
that's three pumps right there.
(graphic whooshing)
And the quarterback, Ransom, under center,
last five minutes of the game, the Rhinos
are marching here again.
- [Geoff] Hard to stop this
team from scoring, Bill,
they have so many weapons.
- [Bill] Ransom takes the
snap, and it's a shovel pass
to McCringleberry,
through, he's at the 10!
He's at the five!
And touchdown, Rhinos!
- [Geoff] Oh my, great
block by Hardunkichud,
and that's gonna be tough for the Cougars
to come back from.
- [Bill] Boy, what a career
day from Hingle McCringleberry,
the rookie outta Penn State.
Oh, he's just amazingly
fired up here today, Geoff.
- [Geoff] You gotta love
the way this guy plays,
and he, oh-
- [Bill] Oh, see now there's one pump, oh-
- [Geoff] Uh-oh.
- [Bill] Well I cannot believe this kid.
- [Geoff] You gotta put your team first
in situations like this,
and McCringleberry's
just not doing that-
- [Bill] Oh, now there's
two, Geoff now if he
pumps a third time, he
will draw his third penalty
for today.
(Geoff sighing)
Everybody here waiting with bated breath.
- [Geoff] He did it!
- [Bill] Oh, did he?
- [Geoff] Yes, he did it.
- [Bill] Oh, that's just-
- [Geoff] He couldn't help himself-
- [Bill] That's just
amazing, I mean, come on
in professional football, it's really-
- [Geoff] It's a shame-
- [Bill] Yes-
- [Geoff] That's what it is-
- [Bill] Yes, it is.
- [Geoff] You can argue all you want-
- [Bill] Right.
- [Geoff] But the flag,
well it's been thrown.
- [Bill] That's right, if it's three pumps
the ref's not gonna take it away now.
- [Geoff] No he's not,
duration and intensity
doesn't make any difference.
- [Bill] Well Geoff, let's
have a look at the replay here
to see if indeed he
did do the three pumps.
- [Geoff] All right, no question, there is
the first one, right?-
- [Bill] Yeah, agreed, right.
- [Geoff] And then coming up,
is the second one.
- [Bill] Okay, yes, very clear.
It's the third-
- [Geoff] We'll see, it's
coming up right here-
- [Bill] Just not sure.
Oh, yeah, you're right,
there's absolutely three pumps there.
- [Geoff] Oh.
- [Bill] Uh, apologies
to all those watching
with young children,
clearly unintentional.
(upbeat music)
♪ Oh I want you ♪
♪ But I know me ♪